und wir begrüßen in berlin zum phönix
tagesgespräch lars klingbeil
generalsekretär der spd und mitglied des
deutschen bundestages gewählt per
direktmandat 2017 grüße sie in die
hauptstadt herr lincoln klingbeil
stringent und konsequent so hat die
bundeskanzlerin gestern formuliert das
ist die neue linie beim infektionsschutz
in deutschland das ist eine blaupause
das ist schon ein historischer schritt
den wir da gehen
wie wollen sie das genau machen vor
allen dingen dass das verfassungsfest
bleibt das ist in der tat ganz wichtiger
schritt eine entscheidende phase jetzt
in der bekämpfung der pandemie und nach
doch ein paar wochen auch der der unruhe
der instabilität wo wir gesehen haben es
wurde uneinheitlich ist es kaum klar
gewesen für die bürgerinnen und bürger
in diesem land welche regeln jetzt
eigentlich gelten haben wir uns zu
diesem schritt entschieden jetzt
kompetenzen auch für einen begrenzten
zeitraum auf die bundesebene zu ziehen
das passiert wir machen das in einem
geordneten verfahren wir werden im
parlament beginnt jetzt ja in diesen
stunden diskutieren ich bin mir auch
sicher da wird das eine oder andere noch
mal kritisch angeguckt und ich hoffe
dass die opposition einen konstruktiven
weg findet das ganze zu begleiten weil
am ende geht es doch um ein politisches
signal dass wir jetzt in der
entscheidenden phase der pandemie
bekämpfung eine politische einigkeit
haben dass wir bundeseinheitliche regeln
im land haben aber auch ein ganz klares
signal an die bürgerinnen und bürger
dass die politik sich kümmert die
menschen gut durch diese phase zu
bringen daher klingt weil der weiß schon
der appelle an die fraktionen
oppositionsfraktion natürlich auch
ordentlich mitzumachen im vorfeld hat
das nicht so gut geklappt sie hätten ja
einfach das verfahren anstreben können
werden sie genügend oppositionsfraktion
mit ins boot bekommen hätten und hätten
dann die zwei drittel mehrheit gebraucht
warum hat das eigentlich nicht geklappt
das kann ich noch nicht beantworten das
hat ja wahnsinn ministerpräsidenten auch
länger gedauert die brauchten zeit zum
nachdenken aber wir sind jetzt in einer
phase wo es druck braucht wenn es nach
uns gegangen wäre hätten wir diese woche
schon entscheiden können es gab aber
appelle doch noch ein paar tage dran zu
hängen jetzt gehe ich fest davon aus
dass in der kommenden woche vielleicht
sogar
mittwoch schon der bundestag und dann
noch zügig der bundesrat wenn es
notwendig wird entscheiden können und
das ganze in kraft tritt will hier aber
auch sagen die länder sind ja heute
schon in der lage durchaus maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wenn wir täglich auf die
zahlen gucken dann sehen wir die
instanzen gehen nach oben was genau so
alarmierend es ist aber in der tat auch
das sind die belegung der intensivbetten
die gehen drastisch nach oben es gibt
gerade deutliche mahnung aus der
wissenschaft auch vom medizinischen
personal und deswegen muss niemand jetzt
auf den bund warten um in den ländern zu
entscheiden
es gibt die bundesländer die auch
deutlich abweichen wie zb bayern da muss
was passieren aber mein wunsch mein
klarer appell ist dass wir unseren
politischen berlin darauf einigen dass
wir spätestens nächste woche die
notbremse dann auch bundeseinheitlich
verankert haben und sie dann zügig
umgesetzt werden kann gibt auch
bundesländer die tatsächlich jetzt schon
ein bisschen darüber hinausgehen das
bundesland aus dem sie stammen
niedersachsen liegt damit ganz vorn
dabei gibt aber auch spd-geführte
bundesländer die jetzt schon ein
bisschen auch nochmal nachbesserungen
anmelden zum beispiel malu dreyer
rheinland pfalz spricht hier ganz klar
noch mal dass man über rechtsfolgen und
verhältnismäßigkeit noch mal sprechen
müssen sind sie da gesprächsbereit und
wo muss noch gesprochen werden diese
gespräche wird es definitiv geben wir
haben am freitag auch eine anhörung im
parlament und auch die spd
bundestagsfraktion hat er gestern gesagt
es muss und rechtsmäßigkeit gehen
sie wissen dass eine ganz prominente
debatte beispielsweise die frage der
ausgangs beschränkung ist also kann man
eigentlich um 21 uhr noch eine runde
joggen gehen da wird sicherlich darüber
diskutiert auch die beteiligung des
bundestages an künftigen verordnung auch
da wird es große debatten geben aber die
können wir auch in dieser kurzen zeit
führen das traurig und satz
parlamentariern zu wichtig war jetzt der
schritt der kanzlerin und von olaf
scholz zu sagen wir wollen das ganze
bundeseinheitlich regeln wir wollen das
schnell wir wollen eine verständlichkeit
für die bürgerinnen und bürger und ich
merke dass bei uns in der spd einigkeit
darüber herrscht dass wir diesen weg
gehen wollen da mag es detail debatten
geben aber wir sind in der lage das
verfahren jetzt schnell abzuschließen
und das ist ein wichtiges signal für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
also vom timing her erste lesung am
freitag dann anfang nächster woche die
anhörung dann mittwoch beschlussfassung
zweiter dritter lesung
bundestag und kommenden freitag der
bundesrat also es geht das strafgesetz
nichts geht so rein wie es dann später
rauskommen wird
sie haben die ausgangssperren
angesprochen in einem interview gestern
hatten sie glaube ich wenn ich das recht
erinnere schon erklärt dass ich selber
auch als parlamentarier auch ein
bisschen dafür eintreten wollen dass wir
das ein bisschen aufklaren denn die er
soll forscher die lachen sie ja ein
bisschen aus wird sagen freunde draußen
passiert hier nichts drin ist das
entscheidende
also das muss man auch genauer hingucken
wenn man einmal karl lauterbach an der
stelle zu hört dann sieht man nimmt auch
dort wo abends gruppen zusammenkommen da
gibt es auch tröpfcheninfektion also
ganz so einfach ist es nicht und die
ausgangs beschränkung die ja teilweise
schon umgesetzt werden ländern die haben
immer das ziel abends mobilität
einzugrenzen also man geht ja dann
irgendwohin um menschen zu besuchen oder
in der tat auch die ansammlung von
großen menschengruppen jetzt für einen
gewissen zeitraum zu unterbinden
aber das spazierengehen das mit dem hund
gehen das joggen das ist in der tat eine
sache über die geredet wird jetzt in die
nächste tage wo ich auch vermutet ist
kommt dann noch zu änderungen das hat
viel mit der verhältnismäßigkeit zu tun
also da warten wir den kommenden stunden
auch in der parlamentarischen beratung
hat und in der tat ist es so wir haben
ein parlament das vor ort dann auch die
gänge vertritt wir haben eine opposition
die mitreden will
und die einladung das zusammen
hinzukriegen die ist ja an die
opposition auch da das ist ein weg diese
politische geschlossenheit wie beim
anfang der fand in jacken die brauchen
wir auch jetzt in dieser entscheidenden
phase und da hoffe ich dass die
opposition kein krawall macht dass man
kein wahlkampf startet sondern dass man
sich auf diesen schwierigen weg auch
gemeinsam eines und das für konstruktive
gespräche im parlament führen werden
also wir können davon ausgehen dass
trotz alledem dieses gesetz aber sicher
auch die arbeitsschutzverordnung zur
test angebotspflicht juristisch
ausgetestet werden und auch angegriffen
werden das eine ist ja auch durchaus
schon angekündigt wurden vom
mittelstandsverband lassen sie uns noch
den letzten punkt ansprechen
sie haben sich dieser tage auch geäußert
sie regieren aktuell noch fünf monate in
einer großen koalition zu dem was beim
koalitionspartner im moment passiert da
ist die k frage aktuell ungeklärt wenn
es eine partei gibt die erfahrung hat
durchaus mit therapie modus dann ist
sind das die sozial
raten sie erinnern sich selber noch gut
diesen zeitraum gefühl 20 monate aber
von februar 2018 bis november 2009 10 wo
ja auch verschiedene parteivorsitzende
die tür von innen und außen jeweils
genommen haben
sie hatten relativ schnell den ernstfall
für die union erklärt aber jetzt mal
ganz ernsthaft gefragt wie stark
beeinflusst das für sie jetzt das
alltagsgeschäft dieser ungeklärte frage
also in der tat beeinflusst dass die
koalition gerade massiv ich schauen sie
wie lange wir gebraucht haben um eine
testpflicht für unternehmen sie haben
das gerade angesprochen etwas was doch
völlig selbstverständlich sein müssen
zeiten wo familien belastet sind profile
nicht mehr können aber der einzige ort
an dem ich nicht vernünftig getestet
wird sind die betriebe so das haben
jetzt durchgesetzt das hat mit der union
lange gedauert
gestern stand zum dritten mal glaube ich
im kabinett eigentlich auf der
tagesordnung die streichung des rasse
begriffs ist wieder runter genommen
worden weil die union nicht eins ist
dieser permanente wahlkampf der gerade
in der union stattfindet der lehnt das
regierungshandeln und die sagen gestern
hatten wir eine konstruktive debatte in
der fraktion über das
infektionsschutzgesetz die scheint es
bei anderen fraktionen auch gegeben
haben 40 wortmeldungen bei uns nur die
unionsfraktion hat sich um sich selbst
gedreht hat sich mit sich selbst
beschäftigt und das halte ich für
unverantwortlich
in einer solchen phase in der wir gerade
sind über monate wusste man dann muss
man die k-frage kehren jetzt rasen die
züge in der union auf einander zu das
macht die partei handlungs und kriecht
wir haben das von einem jahr geklärt wir
sind politikfähig wir sind geschlossen
wir sind in der lage gerade gut zu
regieren weil wir die hausaufgaben
gemacht haben
die union hat das lange vor sich
hergeschoben und ich halte das für nicht
verantwortbar ich glaube das muss sich
in der tat so deutlich auch sagen dass
dieser union auch nach den letzten
monaten mit der masken affäre mit all
dem was da passiert ist das den eine
auszeit auf der oppositionsbank nach der
bundestagswahl ich gut tut die spd geht
selbstbewusst in diesem wahlkampf das
war sozusagen das personal nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz von lars
klingbeil im phoenix tagesgespräch
spd-generalsekretär und mitglied des
deutschen bundestages danke für das
gespräch sehr gerne alles gute